are kind of like back and forth on
what's more important Halo or gears and
I know this is a little off topic but
like I gotta I gotta agree with Miles
like I think Halo Halo created the
foundation for for Microsoft but I
honestly feel like gears on the 360 air
made it more mainstream oh so he's
saying guess is the new new year
and I'm sorry like you know there is
from what I've seen because obviously
after when I was going to play Gears
four I wasn't going to go play those old
gears games on the 360 at the time
backwards compatibility was the thing so
I just looked up YouTube videos and a
lot of those those cut scenes man I
can't imagine what it was like when you
were playing those back in the day and
they killing off main characters like
walking dead segments like it's like you
don't see that in Halo